so
Keck Quattrupel you
Wo hab ich denn hier liegen?
Vor allem warum, warum hab ich das hier liegen?
Häh?
Wunderbar, dass ich mal Zeug nicht finde, Leute, ich müsste unbedingt mal wieder aufräumen,
ich sag's euch, hier sieht's teilweise aus, Amazon Kartons aufeinander, Kabels aufeinander,
Zeug auf dem Schrank, Zeug auf dem Sofa,
ich muss es echt schon wieder aufräumen, wird echt schöner Zeit,
viel random Stells überall am Start hier, naja,
warten wir's mal ab, gucken ob ich mich dazu durchringen kann,
spätestens an Weihnachten, wenn ich einen Monat Urlaub hab,
wobei so wie ich mich kenne, schieb ich das dann auch wieder ewig auf und mach's dann
doch nicht, lul, so, Frankfurt, komisch, Frankfurt,
ich hab jetzt übrigens wieder die Audio-Settings gefunden, wie ich sie die ganze Zeit habe,
jetzt hört sich's auch wieder halbwegs normal an, nicht so wie den letzten Streams vorher,
nur ich muss aufpassen, ich hab's letztes Mal lauter gestellt, warte mal, ich muss mal
Krach machen, Sekunde, Krach, nee, passt,
klippt hier an der richtigen Stelle, alles gut, so gehört's, exquisite,
über's 4-Sekunden-Delay-Refresh mal den Browser, ja, macht es mal,
Teams wieder, fuck, Teams hat verstellt, Moment, natürlich,
Moment, Moment, Teams hat natürlich wieder verstellt,
aber nicht viel, nicht viel, nicht, ja, so, so ist gut, genau,
jetzt passt das eigentlich alles, so ist ganz gut, Lautstärke, exellent,
was, was, keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung, ich wusste gar nicht,
dass da, dass da Frazier irgendwo bei Instagram in der Werbung drin ist,
das Beste ist, du schaust Stream und machst dabei Hausaufgaben,
für Inklaps, okay, sagt mir nix, heute, warte mal, wir halten,
nein, das stimmt nicht, heute machen wir es, glaube ich, noch, Mod-Check,
Mod-Check, ich glaube, es sind keine Monster, Mod-Check,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das bearbeite, ich hab keine Ahnung,
ich warte, ich warte, bis die, bis die Monsters ändern,
ach, da ist er doch, da ist er doch, wunderbar, null, heute bastel ich
ein bisschen an dem neuen Raspberry Pi rum, der meine Heizung ausliest
unten im Keller, ich hab euch ja schon öfters mal mein Heizungs-Dashboard
gezeigt, das Problem ist nur, dass das Heizungs-Dashboard broken war,
warum war das broken, weil das Kabel kaputt war,
normalerweise sieht man dann hier so Sachen wie Heizungfehler,
ob da Brenner an ist, Temperatur und sowas, aber das ist broken,
das Heizungs-Dashboard, so, und ich hab mir jetzt ein Raspberry Pi
rausgesucht aus der Kiste und hab ein neues Kabel bestellt zum
Auslesen von der Heizung, also die Heizung, ich zeig's noch mal,
ist eine, boah, 222, irgendetwas, nee, ich glaub 222F ist es nicht,
also, ja, genau, so, so ungefähr sieht meine Heizung aus,
das hab ich euch ja schon mal, was kostet denn so was auf Amazon,
zeig mal her, ein Schnapper, genau, so ein Teil hab ich,
und da vorne dran ist ein Anschluss, da vorne ist ein Anschluss,
genau so einer, und da braucht man so einen Kabel für und das
Kabel, was ich hatte, war irgendwie kaputt, so, und dann bin ich
auf Ebay gegangen, ich kauf jetzt sonst nie was auf Ebay,
und hab mir für, ja, so, für in dem Dreh, ich glaub für 35 Euro
oder so, hab ich mir so ein Kabel, null, was ist für den Leuten los,
95 Euro, das ist einfach nur ein serielles Kabel, also, naja,
USB mit zwei Infrarot-LEDs, sowas kannst du für 30 Cent selber
bauen, Wahnsinn, Frederiks, Dankeschön für den Sub, also,
ich will jetzt nicht darüber, über die Heizungswahl an sich
diskutieren im Stream, sondern, wie ich das auslesen kann,
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, was es ist, es ist auf jeden Fall
eine Gas-, es ist Heizung für Gas, und sie funktioniert.
Hast du schon den Impfspot von Inscope gesehen? Nee, zeig mal her,
zeig mal. Da kommen doch jetzt wieder die ganzen Leute, die
irgendwelche, was ich, komischen Dinger sich zusammenspinnen und sagt,
der Nico ist jetzt quasi auf der falschen Seite und flame übelst
rum, oder? 100 Pro, 100 Pro, ich kann es mir so richtig vorstellen.
Naja, genau, da kommt dann sowas wie Teil des Systems, alles nur
noch Schlafschafe und sowas in der Richtung, ich kann es mir schon
richtig vorstellen. Naja, Brainwashing, genau. So, also,
Heizungsdashboard kaputt, was wir heute machen ist folgendes,
ich habe mir einen neuen Raspberry Pi, also das stimmt gar nicht,
ich habe keinen neuen Raspberry Pi gekauft, ich habe noch einen
Raspberry Pi aus der Kiste gebuddelt und habe mir auf eBay
so ein neues Optolink-Kabel gekauft für 40 Euro so in dem Dreh.
Alter, warum wollen die 95, sind die von allen guten Geistern
verlassen? Alter, 95 Euro. So, ich habe mir für 40 Euro so in dem
Dreh 35, 40 irgendwie sowas, habe ich mir ein neues Kabel
geholt. Ach ja, übrigens, dann hat der Empfänger angerufen,
der Versender hat mich angerufen von eBay, hat gemeint,
das war irgendein Ahmed sonst was, also ich habe ihn nur ganz
schlecht verstanden, da heißt es wirklich so und ganz schlecht
verstanden und er meint irgendwie, haben falsches Konto. Da habe
ich gesagt, hä? Nee. Ich habe auf richtiges Konto überwiesen,
weil ich habe Kabel schon hier. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht
kennt das, man fängt dann auch an so komisches Deutsch zu
reden. CDFEDC, ist das Hex für irgendwas? Danke für den
Sub. Zu Dezimal. Kommt da raus? Nix. Warum kommt da nichts raus?
So. Nee. Ist das Max Int, Max Int 32? Nee, was ist das denn?
Ist das irgendwas spezielles? Nö. Ich weiß es nicht. So, zumindest
hat er da angerufen, hat gemeint, falsches Konto, falsches
Konto. Da habe ich gesagt, hä? Wie falsches Konto? Was denn?
Ich habe auf falsche Konto überwiesen. Ja, warum haben
Sie es denn dann losgeschickt, wenn das auch falsches, falsches,
falsches Konto ist? Ja, die Bank zurück überweisen und nochmal
überweisen. Ja, aber Sie haben doch geschrieben, es hat sogar
noch ein paar Euro gefehlt für Versand und und sie schicken
es erst los, wenn es Geld da ist. Warum ist denn jetzt das
Geld nicht da, nachdem Sie gesagt haben, sie schicken es
erst los, wenn das Geld da ist und dann ist ihm aufgefallen.
Oh, habe ich mich vertan? Hat noch einer gekauft? Der meint
die gar nicht mich, aber erst mal die Leute verwirren er.
eBay, Alter, eBay ist echt immer so ein abenteuerliches Ding,
aber ansonsten war der wirklich, kann es nichts sagen, war
nett, hat das Ding ordentlich verpackt, hat es ordentlich
verschickt, sehr guter Verkäufer. Nee, das war kein
Scam-Versuch, glaube ich nicht. Der war wirklich verwirrt
und ich habe mal bei dem geguckt, der, nein, nein, nein,
Leute, das war kein Scam-Versuch, das glaube ich nicht.
Der hat ja noch mehr solcher Dinger im Angebot, das war
kein Scam-Versuch. Mein Dashboard öffentlicher, da gibt es
nichts, das ist Grafana, das ist öffentlich, also Grafana
kann für jeden, erinnert mich an einen Prometheus-Exporter,
der ist nicht öffentlich. Zumindest, ich habe mir ein neues
Kabel bestellt und habe mir gedacht, hey, mein Raspberry
Pi Zero im Keller, den könnte ich doch mal rausschmeißen.
Den könnte ich doch mal rausschmeißen, also habe ich
den Raspberry Pi 3 rausgebuddelt aus einer Kiste und habe
den jetzt in den Keller gestellt und alles angeschlossen,
was ich brauche. Ich habe den eigenen Prometheus-Exporter
für die Heizung. Ja, ich kann ihn dir leider nicht zeigen,
weil das schon eine Weile kaputt ist. Das Kabel war kaputt.
Ja, das ist ein eigener Prometheus-Exporter, der exportiert
Brennerstatus, Fehlerstatus, Wassertemperatur, Kessel-
Temperatur, Abgastemperatur und Pumpleistung. Also die
wichtigen Sachen, ja. Eigener Prometheus-Exporter. In Go?
Nein, in.NET? Moment, warte mal. In was habe ich? Nee, nee,
nee, nee. Doch, doch. Vergiss es. Doch, doch. Das ist, das
ist, das ist in.NET. Ich habe, glaube ich, am Anfang haben
wir versucht, den Prometheus-Exporter irgendwie
Python-mäßig zusammen zu puddeln und das ging mir dann
so auf den Keks, dass ich, dass ich irgendein.NET Zeug
gestrickt habe dafür. Nee, nee, nix in Go. Könnte man
aber auch genauso gut in Go machen. Den, den, den, den
Exporter könnte ich öffentlich machen. Ja, aber den habe
ich hier, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr. Mal kurz gucken.
Oh, übrigens hier meine Heizung. Ich habe nämlich extra
die Kamera jetzt so hingemacht, dass man, dass man sieht,
was, was Sache ist. Dass, dass wir, dass wir quasi heute
zugucken können, ob das fernsteuernde Heizung
richtig funktioniert. Ah ja, huge IP liegt, Leute. Seid
ihr schon drin, ja?
Da fehlt Druck, Lull. Weiß ich nicht, ob da Druck
fehlt. Da steht Druck zwischen eins und zwei ist okay.
Aktuell ist nur warm Wasser an und keine Heizung. Das
heißt, der braucht zum Pumpen nicht wirklich viel
Druck. Ich würde mal sagen, das ist in Ordnung. So,
übrigens mir ist aufgefallen, man sieht, seht ihr denn,
den Bildschirm sieht man gar nicht richtig. Keck wie
erste Service, machen wir morgen Mittag weiter. XY Koordinaten,
ja, hier, mitten am Äquator. So, und ich kann jetzt
erst mal die Infrarot-LED aufmachen. Das steht im
Keller, ja. Ich mache jetzt erst mal Infrarot-LED aus
und da wird man sehen, wenn ich die Infrarot-LED ausmache,
dann sieht man auch besser was auf dem Display. Das
spiegelt ansonsten nur richtig, richtig eklig. Guck,
es sind grad 20 Grad außen und 37 Grad irgendwie
Kessel oder so. Keine Ahnung, was uns das genau sagt.
Zumindest sieht man darauf dann auch, falls sich der
Modus ändert, mal die Infrarot-LED wieder an. Also
Ziel für heute, mit der Infrarot-LED sieht man
halt auch viel besser hier den Druck drauf. Übrigens
wisst ihr, wie ich das festgemacht habe, die Kamera
davor? Richtig big brain. Ich habe, hast du eine
Eigentumswohnung? Nein, ich habe Eigentumshaus. Also
ja, ich habe eine Extended Advanced Eigentumswohnung.
Also, wie ich das dran gemacht habe, ist folgendes,
ich hatte noch so einen Haken von meiner Werkzeugwand
oder habe ich mir gedacht, klar, wenn ihr einen
Custom-Exporter braucht, klar, schieß los, mache ich
euch. Gar kein Ding, macht mir sogar Spaß sowas. Nee,
nee, kommt ruhig zu mir, wenn ihr Custom-Exporter
braucht. Ich bin auch der Def-Biz-Zack-Opps, euch
zertraut. Das wollte ich jetzt zeigen, genau,
Werkzeugwand. Genau, ich habe so ein Teil hier bei
mir im Serverraum hängen und da wurden so ein paar
Haken mitgeliefert hier, so Metallhaken. Und das da
ist eines dieser Metallhaken. So, und wie habe ich
das an die Heizung dran gekriegt? Ich hatte mir mal
vor einer Weile, das war wirklich Zufall, da gab es
bei irgendeinem Amazon Prime-Dray gab es so eine
Packung mit 150 Magneten, also so richtig brutalen
Magneten. Also so Dinger, wenn ihr die aus 10 cm
herunterfallen lässt und der Finger ist dazwischen,
das tut aber ordentlich weh. So ganz 150 kleine
Magnete sind das. Und, oder nee, ich glaube 150
ist ein bisschen viel, 100, 100 würde ich sagen.
War schon eine ganz schöne Menge. Und da habe ich
einfach hier ein Magnet dran gemacht und habe es
einmal oben und einmal unten dran gepappt und hier
vorne steht halt die Kamera drauf. Ja, ja, das ist,
ich denke schon, dass es Neodym-Magnete sind,
die sind richtig brutal fest, aber es geht halt,
weil die, ja, die sind halt nicht so groß.
Kurz auf meinem zweiten Rechner starten.
Seit wann eigene 7TK-Anlage, wie kommst du denn
da drauf? Amazon.de. Alter Amazon, kann ich mal
meine Order-Historie gucken, dann kann ich euch
zeigen, was das Firma, nee, darf ich nicht, darf
ich nicht in meine Order-Historie gucken. Achso,
auf dem anderen Desktop, ein lokaler ZIP-Kline.
Ja, das war das, was wir im letzten Stream gemacht
haben. Im letzten Stream habe ich, Moment, Moment,
Paint, Paint, wir haben tolles Bild gemalt dafür,
ZIP-Magic. Das letzte Mal haben wir das da
programmiert. Klingel per Decked-Gateway an die
Fritzbox, von da an ein eigenes Programm von mir,
dort den ZIP-Call plus das Kamerabild zu einem
neuen ZIP-Call gemacht und bei mir ins Handy
geschickt. Ich glaube, wir sind gekommen bis Call
geht ans Handy, aber Video haben wir noch nicht
gemacht. Gibt es für die Heizung nichts Fertiges
zum Auslesen der Daten? Doch, es gibt von Wiesmann
was Fertiges. Das Problem dabei ist, das kostet
irgendwie 800 Euro und lässt sich null integrieren
in irgendwas anderes. Da habe ich keinen Bock
drauf. So, wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben?
Was für ein UML-Diagramm ist das? Das ist gar
kein UML-Diagramm. Das ist Max Spezial-Klassen-Design
Ishikawa-Diagramm. Also wirklich. Das ist genau
das ist PKD. Also, wo bin ich? Ich wollte euch
doch jetzt irgendwie erzählen, was wir machen.
Also, genau. So, das Ziel heute ist, ich gehe auf
den Raspberry Pi im Keller und dann versuchen wir
das mal wieder einzurichten mit Werten auszulesen
aus der Heizung. Dazu gibt es ein fertiges
Open-Source-Projekt auf GitHub. Nennt sich so
V-Control-D. Muss mal kurz den Dark-Reader ausmachen.
So, V-Control-D, das ist irgendwas ganz eklig
in C zusammengewurschteltes und damit kann man
dann die Heizung abfragen. So, also was ich gemacht
habe für das Dashboard, wohlgemerkt das Dashboard
werden wir heute nicht zum Laufen kriegen. Das will
ich auch anders machen. Also, ich erzähle mal
der Reihe nach. Also, das Dashboard hat
folgendermaßen funktioniert. Auf dem Raspberry Pi
ist dieser V-Control-D drauf, der macht die
Kommunikation mit der Heizung über so ein Optolink-Kabel.
So, und dieses Optolink-Kabel ist eigentlich was
total super Simples. Das sind zwei Infrarot-LEDs
hier, also Empfänger und Sender und bei der
Heizung sind auch zwei Infrarot-LEDs. Das ist
ganz oldschool serielles Geplinke, halt bloß
über USB. Das ist quasi Technik von vor 20
Millionen Jahren. Das ist uralt. Das konnten
schon irgendwelche Einzeller im Meer. Das ist
ganz, ganz, ganz alt. Und älter als ich ist das
auf jeden Fall. So, und dieses Programm ist
auf dem Raspberry Pi drauf im Keller. Dazu
kommt es, der Prometheus-Exporter, der
connectet sich dann per TCP-Socket zu diesem
V-Control-D und liest den Kram aus, exportiert
das Ganze in einem Format, wie man das als
Prometheus-Daten braucht. Dann wird es abgefahren,
dann kommt es ins Grafana. Ich will danach noch
ein anderes Programm drauf passen, also diesen
Prometheus-Exporter, den bauen wir neu. Und zwar
ich will nicht nur Prometheus exportieren, ich
habe mir gedacht, wir machen es jetzt advanced.
Wenn ich es schon neu baue, dann richtig. Und
das probieren wir heute aus. Also, bisher habe
ich nur Werte aus der Heizung ausgelesen. Also
ich habe ausgelesen, keine Ahnung, äh, letzten
Fehler, aktuelle Kessel-Temperatur,
Wassertemperatur, sonst was. Heute will ich
mal probieren, ob ich es irgendwie schaffe, dass
ich Werte setzen kann in die Heizung, also dass
ich zum Beispiel die Betriebsart umschalten
kann zwischen warmem Wasser und Heizen und
warmem Wasser. Deswegen ist wichtig, dass wir
den Bildschirm sehen gleich. Dann steht da
nämlich drauf, warmem Wasser und Kaltwasser
und, äh, warmwasser Heizung oder nur warmem
Wasser. So. Was ist das für eine Kamera?
Was ist das für eine Kamera? Eine WISECAM ist das
WISECAM mit Custom-Firmware.
Chat sagt, ich habe gestern meinen DNS-Server
und Kadi in Grafana integriert. Exzellent, exzellent.
So muss man das machen. So, und das, und das
probieren wir heute. Und in einem der nächsten
Streams programmieren wir dann diesen
Exporter. Also wir machen einen Exporter, der
nicht nur exportieren soll, sondern ich möchte
gleichermaßen ins, äh, in meine Heimautomatisierung.
Also das Ziel ist, dass ich in meinem
Home Assistant Dashboard dann einen Knopf
habe, äh, Wintermodus, Sommermodus, wo ich
umschalten kann. So, und wenn ich auf Wintermodus
schalte, dann geht die, dann geht die Heizung
automatisch dann an auf warmem Wasser plus
Heizung und er schaltet die Heizungsthermostate
an den, an den ganzen Heizkörpern im
Gebäude schaltet er die, die Smart-Thermostate
ein. So, und wenn ich dann auf Sommer stelle,
dann soll er halt nur warm Wasser machen.
So, und das Ganze will ich natürlich über
mein, das Dashboard in meinem Home Assistant
steuern können. Und zusätzlich hätte ich
noch gerne mal die ganzen Historie-Sachen
im Grafana. Also sprich, ich brauch beides.
Ich brauch einmal Connect, MQTT Home Assistant
einmal, äh, Prometheus Exporter. Aber das
bauen wir, das bauen wir in einem der
nächsten Streams. Heute guck ich erstmal,
dass ich's zum Laufen bekomme auf dem
Raspberry Pi und, dass ich schaffe, dort
was zu setzen in der Heizung. Dom PC,
Dankeschön für den huge Sub. Torradin
187, sieben Monate Sub-Subscription hier,
jetzt geht's aber rund. Und sorry, falls
ich irgendwie wieder was übersehen hab.
Ich, ich scroll noch mal kurz Chat durch,
weil ich garantiert mir die Hälfte
überlesen hab. Also, wie gesagt, das, also
die Kamera ist eine Wisecam V2. Das ist so
eine hier. Aber mit Custom Firmware. Und
zwar Custom Firmware ist die hier. Ihr
kennt mich doch, ich Custom Firmware
alles. Und um es euch nochmal zu zeigen,
dass es sinnvoll ist, Custom Firmware zu
verwenden, guckt euch das mal an. Ich hab
letztens wieder ein richtig schönes
Beispiel gefunden, dass Custom Firmware
sinnvoll ist. Ihr schaut mal, ich hab
letztens, alter Twitter, geh mir nicht auf
den Sack. So, hier, guck mal, gab Custom
Firmware, das Osram gesagt hat, Lightify
leuchten, funktionieren nicht mehr
richtig. Es ist eine Stufe, also das ist
nicht so, dass die komplett nicht mehr
funktionieren. Erstmal geht nur die Google
Home und Alexa-Integration nicht mehr, aber
die App ist, also die App für lokale
WLAN-Steuerung ist auch End of Life, das
heißt, die wird auch demnächst nicht mehr
funktionieren. Also sprich, da sieht man
mal wieder das Problem, wenn der
Hersteller keinen Bock mehr hat auf
irgendwelche Smart Home Produkte, ist
halt alles im Arsch. So, und insofern,
deswegen mach ich immer Custom Firmware.
Ganz einfach. Blizzard ist am Arsch. Sau
viele kündigen ihr WoW-Abo, ja zu recht.
Ich würde sagen, alle die ihr WoW-Abo
kündigen, haben jetzt ja extra Geld, die
können mich einfach subscriben. Ich werde
auch nie WoW im Stream spielen, versprochen.
McCree wird renamed, ja das habe ich gelesen.
McCree in Overwatch wird remaked, weil
McCree nach irgendeinem Entwickler benannt
war, der wohl in diesem Blizzard-Belästigungsskandal
verwickelt ist. Aber ganz ehrlich, ich
kann es nachvollziehen aus Blizzard-Sicht,
die versuchen ja gerade alles in irgendeine
Art und Weise, dass sie wieder halbwegs
gut dastehen. Ob natürlich jetzt das
Renamen von McCree in irgendeine Art und
Weise die Arbeitsbedingungen verbessert,
beziehungsweise die Leute dort irgendwie
ja besser dastehen lassen, habe ich so
meine Zweifel. Warzone, klar, ich habe
die letzten mal immer nur Warzone-Streams
gemacht. So, genau, das ist die Custom-Firmware
für die Kamera. Und die Custom-Firmware
für die Kamera ist wirklich gut. Also
ihr könnt alles Mögliche einstellen bei
der Kamera. Ihr könnt von Infrarot-LED,
die lokalen LEDs, ihr könnt Motion-Detection
anmachen, die nicht so wirklich gut
funktioniert. Ihr könnt über RTSP,
MJPAC die Videos abrufen, ihr könnt
irgendwelche Notifications über MQTT
verschicken, Sounds an ausmachen, Motion-
und Nachrichten über Telegram, E-Mails,
LEDs blinken, Snapshots speichern auf
der Platte. Also die Kamera ist wirklich
nice mit der Custom-Firmware. Allerdings
eins muss man sagen, die Kamera hat nicht
wirklich guten WLAN-Empfang. Also der
Access Point ist ungefähr zwei Meter
weg im Keller. Den habe ich erst letztens
da aufgehängt und seitdem ist okay.
Ansonsten der WLAN-Empfang dieser
Kamera ist wirklich kacke. So, mal kurz
Chat durch scrollen.
Hast du nur einen Heizkreis für den
Heizkörper oder einen Verteiler mit
Ventil-M? Also ich glaube nicht, dass ich
einen Verteiler mit Ventilen habe. Ich
habe einen Heizkreis, das nennt sich bei
dieser Heizung Heizkreis M1, glaube ich.
Und ich habe nur ganz normal an den
Heizkörpern halt so Thermostate zum
stellen. Zum Beispiel das da habe ich
drei Stück dran.
Fritz deckt.
Übrigens, einzige Fritz-Smart-Home-Gedöns,
was ich habe. Ich muss aber sagen, die
Fritz-Thermostate sind wirklich nicht
schlecht. Max kommt eigentlich noch ein
Azubi-Video. Ja, das nächste Video
erzähle ich euch von unserem Spezial-Azubi,
der versucht hat illegales Streaming
bei uns im Rechenzentrum zu hosten.
Muss ich dann aber super anonymisieren,
dass mir da nichts rausrutscht.
Das mal andere ist nicht schlimm, aber
bei dem. Wobei sie sich ja zum Glück ihn
noch halbwegs rechtzeitig erwischt haben,
aber trotzdem, Alter. Kann man so
bescheuert sein, das verstehe ich bis heute
nicht. War auch der einzige Azubi, der nicht
übernommen wurde. Nicht mal nur alibi-
mäßig ein halbes Jahr.
Es war nicht der Endpunkt diesmal.
Der Endpunkt war damals schon lange weg.
Eigentlich müsste man übernehmen, weil
er so big brain Sachen macht. Ja, ne.
Das Problem bei dem war,
der fand sich so ultra geil.
Da hat mich, ich weiß noch, als der das
erste Mal bei mir war, habe ich ihn
gefragt, das habe ich glaube ich in der letzten
Szene in dem Video erzählt, so dachte ich,
und hast schon mal was mit Linie und so?
Ja, ja, kenne ich mich voll aus. Ja, und wie
sieht es hier da und damit aus? Ja, kenne ich mich
voll aus. Und wie sieht es so ein bisschen mit
Programmieren aus? Ah, kenne ich mich auch
voll aus. Web-Anwendung? Ah, kenne ich mich
auch voll aus. Der hat zu jedem, wo ich ihn
gefragt habe, gesagt, der kennt sich voll gut aus.
Das ist besser. Die Ice-Story.
Stimmt, das muss ich mir erinnern. Die Ice-Story muss ich
auch noch dazu erzählen.
Ja, der gleiche Azubi wollte nämlich mal so einen
Ice-Spring-Service machen,
wo er dann Kohle machen kann in der
Mittagspause. Ach, das war schon,
das war ganz, ganz, ganz spezieller.
Ich mein, er muss ihn ja zumindest lassen.
Tatendrang hatte er.
So, mal kurz durchgucken, dass ich
Chat, nichts.
Das ist doch keine Wasseruhr.
Das ist der Druck an der Heizung.
So sieht doch kein Wasserzähler aus.
Habt ihr schon mal Wasserzähler gesehen?
Das sieht nicht so aus.
So, aber schnell durchscrollen.
Ja, wie gesagt, wahrscheinlich nur einen.
Der Exporter bringt dir aber nur was, wenn du
eine Wiesbarnheizung hast mit genau
meinem, meinem Controller drin.
Fällt mir gerade so an.
Nur 690, danke für den Sub.
21 Monate, Alter.
Hyper-Subscription hier.
Heizung ist nicht kaputt.
Ich hab wieder ein neues Kabel
zur Datenübertragung.
Okay, nice.
Hab ich alles. Also, wie gesagt, fangen wir mal an.
Der hatte richtig Big Brain Business Pläne, ja.
Aber ich glaube, Business Pläne für
den Streaming Service in Deutschland sind
allgemein nicht so...
Ist schwierig, ist schwierig.
Mir fällt gerade ein, ich weiß die IP von
meinem Raspberry Pi nicht.
Warte mal, ich glaube.
129, kann das sein?
Warte mal, sec.
Also, ich hab den schon installiert.
Ähm...
Updates gemacht.
Aber das war's.
Also...
Mehr, mehr gibt's da noch nicht,
was ich drauf gemacht hab.
Ach so, und unbenannt hab ich ihn natürlich.
Die Dinger brauchen den passenden Namen wieder.
Genau.
So, also, dann würde ich sagen, wir fangen mal an.
Also, wir müssen, wir müssen, damit wir
überhaupt das Ganze ausprobieren können.
Ich hoffe übrigens, dass das funktioniert
dann gleich mit dem Erkennen
auf der, auf dem Display,
ob ich umschalte zwischen, sagen wir mal,
Heizung oder nur warm Wasser.
Jemand wollte von Google, die sucht die
Domain 12...
12701,
ja, das hab ich gelesen.
Da siehst du mal, was für Lowbrains da
am Start sind.
Da musste, also, dass du auf so Ideen
kommst, da kannst du nur irgendein
ahnungsloser BWL
Stonksmann sein oder
Anwaltsmann oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Vor allem ohne irgendwie
auch mal Rücksprache mit irgendwelchen Technikern
zu halten, so bescheuerte Ideen musste erst mal kommen.
Also, das war richtig
Neu-Time.
Also V-Control D muss man installieren.
Perfekt, nein, wow.
Ach du Scheiße, da hat man auch
Image-Config-Anpassungen gebraucht, das weiß ich doch jetzt
alles gar nicht mehr, wie das richtig funktioniert hat.
So, installieren, ja, zack,
clone-in.
Shit.
Also, mitmachen, dass Dr.
Disrespect jetzt aufgelöst hat, warum
er gebannt wurde. Echt? Nee?
Warum?
Erzähl warum?
Dr. Disrespect Ban
Kannte er den Grund für den Ban?
Es gibt einen Grund.
Dr. Disrespect will Twitch verklagen.
Okay, zeigt mal her.
Ähm
Die Firmen, das haben sie ja schön
formuliert. Die Firma Twitch
hat eine sehr merkwürdige Regel, wenn es um permanente
Bans geht. Na gut,
die Regel an sich bei Twitch mit
immer Bans und Bans an sich ist eigentlich relativ
einfach. So wie es Twitch
gerade passt.
So grob den Regeln
entsprechen, aber hauptsächlich so wie es Twitch
gerade passt.
Ähm
Ja, und? Da steht überhaupt
nicht. Okay, der Chat
Der Chat weiß es aber wieder.
Woher hast du das? Er hat beim Verhandeln
mit Twitch gesagt, dass er ein Angebot von Mixer
hat, was höher als das von Twitch ist.
Dann kam aber raus, dass er kein Angebot
von Mixer hat. Darauf hat ihn Twitch gebannt. Jetzt
verklagt er mit Mixer. Hat er auch recht.
Also wenn das stimmt, man weiß es ja
nicht, ob das wirklich stimmt.
Aber
wenn das stimmt, hat er recht.
Das ist ja nicht verboten in dem Sinn.
Du kannst ja
viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Aber da sieht man mal, wer am Endeffekt
am längeren Hebel sitzt.
Das ist ja das, was ich auch schon seit einer ganzen
Weile sage. Man sieht mittlerweile
gerade auch dadurch, dass
Trump und Leute
da gesperrt werden, dass
eindeutig die Social Media-Dinger immer
vermehrt hier die Muskeln flexen.
Um zu zeigen, guck mal,
also ihr könnt sonst was sein,
aber an uns kommt ihr nicht vorbei.
Ohne uns geht nichts mehr.
Ich bin ja immer noch
der Meinung, dass da Trump an reines
reines Flexen
von Twitter
war, um zu zeigen,
Jungs, guckt mal hier, so schnell kann es
gehen, wenn ihr Zeug macht, was uns nicht gefällt.
Alles andere
ist nur vorgeschoben, um das irgendwie zu begründen.
Oh man sieht es ja auch, du hast gelitten.
Du hast komplett gelitten, wenn Twitter,
YouTube, Twitch, alle möglichen,
wenn die jetzt heute der Meinung sind, wir bannen dich.
Klar, du kannst die verklagen,
was manche schon vereinzelt erfolgreich
geschafft haben,
aber in der Regel machst du da nichts.
Alles interessant.
Kannst du eine flashbare Smart-Stack-Dose empfehlen?
Das Problem ist,
dass ich nicht weiß, welche sich noch flashen lassen.
Die, die ich habe,
ähm,
die,
wenn du die neu kaufst, wirst du die wahrscheinlich
nicht, nicht flashen können.
Weil die neueste,
weil die neue Tuya-Firmware drauf haben.
Ja gut, das stimmt schon.
Das hat Apple beim App Store auch.
Und das fällt ihnen gerade auf die Füße.
Oder auch nicht, es kostet sie zumindest
ein bisschen Geld. Und auf der anderen Seite
vollkommen egal, ob sie das haben oder nicht,
man muss es ja nicht toll finden.
Klar, letztendlich können die bei Twitch und Twitter
machen, was sie wollen, aber es ist eindeutig
eine Ansage gewesen, spätestens
als sie Trump gebannt haben. Natürlich
haben sie gesagt, ja, das war aus den und den Gründen.
Man könne sich ja schlecht hinstellen
und sagen so nach dem Motto, wir bannen jetzt
den Präsident von den USA,
um zu zeigen, dass wir
das Sagen haben. Aber meiner Ansicht
nach ist das eindeutiges Muskelflexen
von Twitter gewesen.
Du hast Fans aus Norddeutschland.
So, so.
Die Apple-Konferenz
stream ich nicht mehr, Alter. Das ist vorbei.
So, also, jetzt mal hier
zur eigentlichen Geschichte.
Wir müssen den Kram hier kompilieren.
Was für ein Staubsauger-
Porta würdest du empfehlen?
Also,
ich würde mir nicht mehr den kaufen, den ich jetzt habe.
Wenn ich mir jetzt einen kaufen würde,
würde ich mir den da kaufen.
Den S7 mit Absaugstation.
Das Dumme ist nur, dafür gibt es keine
Custom-Firmware.
Also, das müsste ich
dann echt in irgendein abgeschlossenes Netz packen.
Oh ja, mein ganzes IoT-
Zeug eh schon drin ist.
Aber das ist
aktuell der Roboter, den ich mir kaufen würde.
Wenn ich mir einen neuen kaufen würde.
Weil ich finde die Idee
einen Staubsauger-Roboter zu haben,
der sich selbst ausleeren kann.
Richtig nice.
Klar, das Ding ist jetzt, das Ding fast jetzt
vielleicht auch nicht so viel wie ein großer
Staubsauger. Warum nicht die Eltern?
Weil die sich nicht automatisch ausleeren können.
Für mich, also der einzige Grund, warum
ich mir einen neuen Staubsauger-Roboter kaufen würde,
ist, dass der sich selbst ausleeren kann.
Und das ist halt
richtig geil.
Diese Taktik mit dieser Absaugstation.
Und wer leert die Station?
Gut, das muss dann irgendjemand machen.
Aber halt seltener als sonst.
Ja, wenn der alte kaputt ist, kaufe ich mal.
Aber der hält. Der hält. Das Ding ist wirklich
ziemlich stabil.
Also ich kompiliere mir jetzt den Kram. Da wird immer echt Zeit.
Also zack.
Haben wir schon geklont.
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal? Docks.
Also das, was wir hier am Start haben,
das brauchen wir zur Kommunikation mit
der Heizung.
Das liefert mit einmal das Programm,
was direkt mit der Heizung kommuniziert
und einmal so ein Testprogramm.
Wobei das Testprogramm brauchen wir dann später nicht,
weil das lesen wir ja selbst aus.
Für drei Monate.
Huge Subscription hier.
So, also.
Ah, okay, die übliche Geschichte.
Hab ich das überhaupt drauf?
Hab ich den Kram überhaupt installiert?
Aber ich glaube, ich habe alles schon draufgehauen,
was ich brauche. Build Essentials.
Mal gucken.
Ja, sieht gut aus.
Ich hab schon alles drauf.
Nee.
Der sagt mir nicht Bescheid,
wenn er voll ist.
Den musste immer ausleeren, nachdem er
voll ist.
Den musste immer ausleeren,
nach eins, zweimal rumfahren.
Deswegen finde ich ja gerade Roboter,
Saugroboter mit
Ausleerstationen richtig geil.
Der Kopf, bei mir auch.
Was hast du gekriegt?
Also ich hatte auch richtig Kopfweh
im zweiten Tag, oder quasi
den Tag nach der Impfung.
In your face.
So, also,
mkdir build, zack.
cd build
cmake.
Build files have been written to, wunderbar.
So, was gibt's für Optionen?
cmake.
Was ist, was ist
dvsim?
Helperprogramm, nee, brauchen wir nicht.
Ah, ich muss das ganze nochmal machen, ich brauche
Optionen. Ich erinnere mich
noch, noch dunkel dran.
mkdir build.
Manpages machen wir on,
zum nachgucken.
Das komische Programm machen wir off.
So, install prefix.
Ich will das gar nicht in System installieren,
ich will das bei mir ins Heimatverzeichnis installieren.
Wie
Ctrl D oder so.
Mkdir build.
Zack, so, und ich glaube, jetzt können wir
das kompilieren.
Ach ja, übrigens, was ich auch noch auf
diesem Raspberry Pi drauf habe, das wollte ich euch gerade nochmal
zeigen. Ich habe da noch einen Automation
Phead, einen
Automation Fat drauf.
Und zwar,
das
ist so ein kleines, mal
zeigen, ob man das hier irgendwie sieht.
Genau,
das ist so ein kleines Board,
das steckst du auf die
GPIO Aust, also auf die ganzen
Pins vom Raspberry Pi drauf.
Und der hat, Moment, ich muss jetzt mal auf die offizielle
Seite gehen.
Hier.
Ne.
Also, der hat drauf,
ähm,
3 Inputs
Analog-Digital-Converter
bis 24 Volt.
DC Inputs,
Outputs, also sprich,
ähm,
damit kannst du dann,
kannst du dann auch, ähm,
also Inputs kannst
zum Beispiel,
also das sind digitale
Inputs, da siehst du zum Beispiel, wenn
da ein Signal drauf ist,
unter 3 Volt 0 über 3 Volt 1,
aber bis zu 25 Volt tolerant,
das ist halt das Coole daran,
weil der Raspberry Pi, der ist sehr, sehr
pingelig, was Inputspannung
angeht. Wenn du bei dem Raspberry Pi
auf die 3,3 Volt
GPIO Pins 5 Volt
draufmacht, da kannst du dir schon sein,
dass der dir abkackt. Hat es schon mal jemand geschafft von euch?
5 Volt Geräte
auf die 3,3 Volt GPIOs
vom Raspberry Pi, nothing
dabei, es ist auf
jeden Fall nicht dafür gedacht.
Ähm, der Raspberry Pi ist
sehr, sehr pingelig, jeder ESP
32 ist, ist
toleranter als ein Raspberry Pi.
Also der Raspberry Pi, der ist
relativ schnell, ja,
ist man zertge,
weil das Ding im Arsch ist.
So, und die Inputs
sind halt 24 Volt tolerant,
dann hast du noch Outputs, damit kannst
du schalten,
also da machst du dann quasi einen auf
Ground, ne,
bin verwirrt.
Muss ich mal kurz, muss ich mal gucken, damit
kannst du, kannst du, kannst du quasi, ähm,
Geräte schalten, aber maximal
bis 500 mA
und dann hast du noch einen Relay
drauf, wo du dann auch Sachen schalten
kannst, die mehr
als 500 mA brauchen.
Also du kannst quasi,
du kannst quasi
drei Sachen, die nicht
sonderlich viel brauchen, schalten.
Eine, eine,
über das Relay kannst du einen Verbraucher
schalten, der
ein bisschen mehr verbraucht.
Und, äh, ja.
So, und was ich, was ich da mal,
was ich da, wie ich das jetzt
verwenden werde, ist folgendes.
An einem dieser Analog-Digital-Converter
hab ich die Klingel dran.
Das ist das, was ich euch hier letztens
gezeigt hab, hab ich die Klingel dran,
bei diesem SIP an.
Ja, das ist das, was ich euch hier
letztens gezeigt hab, bei
die Klingel, diesem SIP,
ist hier dran angeschlossen
und der erkennt, also
Analog-Digital-Converter
liest dir beispielsweise aus,
wie hoch die Spannung auf der Leitung ist.
So, und die Spannung fällt halt bei mir
oder, ne, die steigt. Also normalerweise
ist auf meiner Klingel, ähm,
der Leitung von der Klingel ist
17 bis 18 Volt und wenn es klingelt,
geht es hoch auf 20 bis 24.
Das heißt, wenn
der ADC hier auf einmal 20 plus
Volt eingelesen hat, dann weiß ich,
ok, bam, es hat geklingelt.
So, und
über die Inputs und die Relays könnte ich da noch,
ähm, zum Beispiel
unten im Keller was schalten, beide,
alles übrigens nur 24 Volt.
Also das Relay,
da kannst du keine 230 Volt oder so
da steht auch, glaub ich, da.
Hier, einmal 24 Volt
at 2 Ampere Relay. Also sprich,
du kannst,
du kannst an das, ähm,
deine Stimme ist heute
ist, ist, ich hab wieder
meine normalen Audio-Settings,
die ich die ganze Zeit hatte.
Ich hatte die letzten,
ich hatten die letzten Streams, hatte ich keine
richtigen Audio-Settings.
Jetzt hab ich wieder endlich mal meine normalen
Audio-Settings,
die ich, die ich sonst auch immer hab.
Muss mich jetzt mal kurz anhören.
Hör ich mich wirklich irgendwie bedeutend anders an?
Also ja, ein bisschen, ein bisschen kann ich verstehen,
aber ansonsten, ich sollte mich...
Ja. Oh.
Oh, ich bin verwirrt.
Fuck. Jetzt, jetzt hör ich mich doppelt und dreifach.
Lul.
Ah.
Oh.
Guck mal hier.
In, guck mal hier.
Stream Inception.
Nee, hört sich eigentlich an wie immer.
Hört sich jetzt aber eher an, wie sich
es anhören sollte im Stream.
Ja, ich hab jetzt irgendwie die ordentlichen Audio-Settings
dafür.
Ja.
Genau.
So, und...
Und den hab ich da auch drauf.
Du hast, also du kannst hier drüber
einmal 24 Volt mit
maximal 2 Ampere schalten
über das Relay.
Und
über die Inputs,
so über die Outputs kannst du
maximal 500 Milli Ampere gehen lassen,
sonst mag er nicht.
Und das ist halt sehr praktisch, weil der Raspberry Pi
ist normalerweise sonst
allem über 3,3 Volt RIP.
Und damit kannst du halt auch ordentlich
normale Geräte mit Schalten
auslesen, sonst wie was.
So, und
wie gesagt, hier hab ich die Klingel dran,
dass ich erkenne, wenn es klingelt. Und hier drüber
könnte ich dann zum Beispiel so Sachen machen wie
ich schalte, oder über das
Relay, ich schalte zum Beispiel diese
Deckstation, die ich unten im Keller hab, aus,
wenn ich will, dass es aufhört zu klingeln an den
Telefon und sowas. Ist ganz
praktisch zu haben, steht alles im Keller, alles in der
gleichen Ecke.
Ja, ich könnte zum Beispiel über das
Relay auch die Heizung resetten oder so,
aus welchen Gründen auch immer
ich die Heizung resetten sollte, aber
könnte ich machen.
So, genau,
das ist auch noch auf dem Raspberry Pi obendrauf.
Aber, Keller
ist die neue Cloud, ja.
Wenn ihr wüsstet, was wir auf der Arbeit
teilweise für
abenteuerliche Zustände in der Cloud
haben, dann glaube ich doch, dass mein Keller
manchmal die bessere Cloud wäre, ja.
Oh, huge
Musik hier.
She played a song as klingel sound, ja, perfekt.
Also, wir wollten den ganzen Kram
kompilieren. So, C Make, Bam,
Make, auf geht's.
I, C++ Ausgaben.
Nee, es ist C, dann ist alles okay.
Wenigstens ist das in einer ordentlichen
Kramiersprache programmiert.
So was wäre an C++ schlecht, weil ich
C++ nicht mag. Das weißt du,
aber das ist einfach nur Chebat im Chat
wieder. Der Chat will mich
Chebaten, dass ich jetzt wieder
15 Minuten über C++
mich aufwege.
Das waren wir jetzt aber nicht.
Also, bei uns beispielsweise,
das war eine Sache zur Skin. Also,
was bei uns anletztens in der Cloud lustig war,
weil das habe ich glaube ich schon mal ansatzweise
hier erzählt,
warum C++, wenn man C-Sharp
hat,
sie wollten beispielsweise
letztens terabyteweise Mail-
Postfläche umziehen.
Und da ist ihnen aufgefallen,
wenn das in Azure ist, ist das halt
abfuckmäßig langsam.
So, und um das schnell zu bekommen,
hat man
SSDs gebraucht. Also,
man musste VMs mit SSDs hinstellen.
Man konnte nicht einfach Azure Files nehmen oder so.
Azure Files mit
NFS angebunden war lahm as fuck.
Also wirklich USB 1.0
Geschwindigkeit.
Weil halt viele kleine Dateien öffnen
und schließen. Über NFS
mit Latency. Ist halt, sagt halt.
So, und da hat man gesagt, okay, man
bräuchte eigentlich VMs und SSDs.
Und
die SSDs
hätten uns 80.000 Euro im
Monat gekostet.
Um unsere
Mails drauf zu speichern. 80.000
Euro im Monat.
Müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Oder hat man sich dann dafür
entschieden, ach nee, man
macht's doch nicht in die Cloud, weil
zu teuer.
Ist auch geil.
Hätten wir auch vorher merken können, aber gut.
Ja, das
ist teuer.
Guckt ihr mal an, was so ein Terabyte
SSD oder gar Premium SSD
in Azure kostet.
Aus dem Weg gering Verdiener.
OnBrem war vor allem billiger.
Aber 80.000 Euro
war schon ordentlich.
Wie viele Mails schreibt ihr? Viele.
Wir haben
über 50.000
ungefähr 50.000 Außendienstleute.
Oder?
Keine Ahnung.
Und?
Wir haben
10 Jahre Archiv von allen Mails.
Könnt ihr euch vorstellen, das ist schon ein bisschen
was.
Da hat sich schon ein bisschen was
angesammelt.
Ja. Also
Make BAM. Ach so, nee, haben wir doch
gerade schon. So, Make
Install.
Wie viel günstiger ist OnBrem?
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen, weil ich
weiß nicht, was unsere aktuelle Storage kostet
hat.
Joshua, kann ich nicht verraten?
Du musst aufpassen, dass hier nichts geleakt
wird.
Sonst kann man hier noch irgendwie
Rückschlüsse auf irgendwas ziehen.
Ich wusste das auch immer. Das
ist übelst kompliziert. Ich muss hier
auch immer, wenn ich im Stream was erzähle, die Sachen
on the fly so anonymisieren.
So.
Also würde ich jetzt stehen geblieben.
Jetzt haben wir den Kram installiert.
Jetzt habt ihr irgendwas mit Ramdisk
gefrickelt. Oh, ich bin auch dafür.
Wir sollen das komplette Archiv in eine Ramdisk
machen.
Ich werde es
weder
B noch D
bestätigen.
Was ist das Gegenteil von bestätigen?
Dementieren.
Genau. Ich werde es weder
Dementieren noch bestätigen.
So.
Und hier haben wir jetzt den Kram,
womit man die Heizung auslesen kann.
V-Ctrl-D.
Bäm. Starten. Geht nicht. Warum?
Weil er nach
etc v-Ctrl-D v-Ctrl-xml
will. Da darfst du nicht hin.
Was hast du verpasst?
Wir haben das Programm zur Heizungssteuerung
runtergeladen und kompiliert. Sonst noch nichts.
Max arbeitet
als V-Tuber. Ja,
ich bin immer noch dabei, mir endlich mal
ein V-Tuber-Keks zu basteln.
XML. Ja, passt mal auf. Nicht einfach
nur XML. Guckt euch mal diese XML an.
Wenn ihr mehr ekliches XML sehen wollt,
dann
haltet euch jetzt mal fest.
XML
300.
Ja.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Und
ich sage mal so tolle Sachen wie
Get Öldurchsatz.
Get
Öldurchsatz.
Get Öldurchsatz.
Richtiger
Liter-Cyclable.
Get Öldurchsatz.
Richtiger
Liter-Cyclable.
Get Ölturchsatz.
Es Roma
congress
enable, ne ach was weiß ich denn aus dem kopf, chat, syntax on, ah ne syntax so was
ne, genau, ich glaub syn geht auch einfach, ja, excellent, bei euch gibt es eine app,
die hat suchvalue als parameter, alter wir haben bei uns in unserer, ich hab letztens
mal wieder was gesehen in unserer java software, jetzt muss ich das wieder anonymisieren im
kopf, aber da steht sinngemäß sowas drinne wie, upload, bestands, verträge, wie sag
ichs jetzt, upload, bestands, verträge, encrypted, so nach dem motto ja, das ist auch ganz mir
bei uns die ganze benahmung von den funktionen, upload, bestands, verträge, factory, genau,
chain lore trägt sich richtig ab, aber das ist tatsächlich ein gutes emote, es ist tatsächlich
ein gutes emote, allerdings werde ich das nicht nehmen, weil, wobei doch ich edit das,
ich edit das, ich edit das zum channel, für das gut, ja und den kreditkarten pepega credit
können wir auch rein machen, ein kumpel von dir hat noch nie java, java, er hat noch nie
programmiert, fängt mit, fängt mit java an, das ist gar nicht so schlimm, kann man
machen, besser als mit c++ anzufangen, also es gibt zum einsteigen eigentlich nur einen
fehler, den man machen kann und das ist mit c++ anzufangen, also alles andere ist sag
man mal noch eh verträglich, aber c++ ist einfach pains jam, du bist für immer verdorben
wenn du mit c++ anfängst, kannst du komplett knicken, also das ist überhaupt nicht schlimm,
ohne probleme kann man mit java anfangen, gar kein ding, gar kein ding, ja so big brain
kann man mit java anfangen, also ich bin ja als einsteiger programmier sprache für javascript,
man kann aber auch irgendwas x-beliebig anderes verbreitetes nehmen, von python bis c-sharp
bis java bis go bis sonst was, aber ich würde ganz ehrlich, ich würde mit javascript anfangen,
heutzutage, einfach weil du da, du brauchst nur einen browser, sonst nix, übrigens wenn
ihr das genauer wissen wollt, wir haben da ein video zugemacht, welche programmier sprache
eignet sich für einsteiger, habe ich zusammen mit algorithm und verstehen gemacht, der ist
big brain matte informatiker stels, da weiss wovon er spricht, und da haben wir eigentlich
alles dazu gesagt, was man so sagen muss, ja aber zum einsteigen ist c glaube ich echt
zu big brain, aber bei c gibt es nicht all zu viel was du lernen kannst, weil die sprache
sehr minimalistisch ist, aber du musst halt wirklich alles selbst machen, standard library
gibt es nicht, aber naja, ich würde nicht von standard library bei c sprechen, also
das hier ist jetzt raspberry pi 3, da hatte ich nämlich noch einen, und es macht keinen
sinn da einen 4er hinzustellen, ich höre mich wieder normal an, nice, weil performance
technisch brauchst du das gar nicht, ja, stimmt alles in assembler, programmiersprachen
sind eh nur bloat, so siehts aus, also jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, dass wir das auslesen
von unserer heizung auf die reihe, von meiner heizung auf die reihe kriegen, also wenn ich
mich jetzt noch richtig erinnern kann, muss man jetzt irgendwie, diesen control, diesen
v control die starten, und dazu muss man ihm eine xml danteil mitgeben, so, also minus
x und dann eins nach oben, v control xml, 300, das habe ich mir gemerkt, dass man 300 machen
muss, weil diese komischen protokolle von diesen wiesmann heizung, es gibt 300, also
dieses protokoll heißt irgendwie 300, und es gibt kw oder so, kw ist das ganz ganz uralte
und 300 ist das bisschen neuere, also ich wollte auf jeden fall 300 haben, ich glaube
kw kann meine heizung gar nicht, so und dann brauchen wir noch hier würde ich sagen minus
n, dass ich sehe was er macht, und wir machen mal einen tmax auf, vielleicht soll ich mir
das vorher noch kopieren, so und jetzt gucken wir mal ob das ganze startet, bäm, hat funktioniert,
startet, und jetzt können wir abfragen und mal gucken ob das funktioniert, ob ich dinger
von meiner heizung abfragen kann, client, das ist so nur so ein testprogramm, minus host
minus port also, minus host 1270.0.1, also das was google letztens löschen sollte, port
3002, und dann muss man minus command oder so sagen, minus c, so und jetzt können wir
uns was raussuchen, ich weiß zum beispiel dass man die heizung abfragen kann mit get
error 0, das kenne ich, oh, ah die settings stimmen nicht, die settings stimmen nicht,
mein serieller anschluss ist nicht tty sack 1, sondern ich glaube tty usb, ja, das müssen
wir noch anpassen, hier, da, usb 0, so und ansonsten keine ahnung was dieser kann, ihr
müsst euch das mal angucken, die dinger sind teilweise so grausam, temper, ich meine guckt
euch das mal an, wer nennt denn bitte sein zeug, temperatur 1 byte ganzzahlig, jetzt
mal ernsthaft, welcher hersteller macht solche sachen alter, ich will den wiesmann source
code gar nicht sehen bei denen, prozent 1 byte ganzzahlig, counter s, prozent 1st byte,
return status, error state, kurzschluss, außentemperatursensor, ich weiß immerhin versteht man was darunter
ist, was dahinter ist, ok, jetzt haben wir das angepasst, gucken wir mal ob es jetzt
funktioniert, get error 0, hey funktioniert, also der letzte fehler von meiner heizung
ist vom 9.06, das ist glaube ich kokona, kokona format, warum auch immer, temperaturbekenzer
ausgelöst, um 9.42 am 9.06.2021 um 10 Uhr unserer zeit würde ich mal sagen, 10.42,
das ist mal richtig code der sich selbst dokumentiert, ja so siehts aus, so also, so kann man die
heizung auslesen, allerdings, allerdings, und jetzt wirds ein bisschen komplizierter,
ich kann sowas abrufen wie, das weiß ich noch, man kann sowas wie, get betriebsart
kann man zum beispiel, oder was, get betrieb art kann man machen, und jetzt wirft er der
heizung, das ist ok, aktuell läuft die heizung nur mit warmem wasser, was ja auch passt,
was ihr hier eventuell seht, also ich glaube, wenn es heizen plus warmem wasser wäre, dann
wäre hier irgendwie so ein heizungssymbol, und hier unten wäre es ein brenner, hier
unten wäre auf jeden fall ein brenner, heizung liegt, fuck alter, habt ihr euch schon wieder
eingehackt, ja, ich sehs schon, ich muss gleich die cyber nuke starten, um euch wieder los
zu werden, sehs schon, mit welchem tool sollte man vm am besten aufsetzen, vm workstation,
ne, ne, vm workstation ist gerade wenn du auf windows bist das beste, also für desktop
virtualisierung unter windows ist vm workstation das beste, und vm workstation kriegst du
die lizenzen auch relativ günstig bei dem keyshop, ok, also weiter gehts, so, also get
betrieb art können wir machen, jetzt muss ich mal schauen, ob es auch sowas wie set
betrieb art gibt, ich fürchte nämlich nicht speed controls, grab set betrieb art, doch
guck mal, ah, aber nicht für meine heizung, es gibt nur für das alte protokoll, set betrieb
art, ich will aber set betrieb art machen, das heisst wir müssen jetzt irgendwie raus
kriegen wie man einen eigenen befehl dahin zufügt, das wird grausam, aber wohlgemerkt
set betrieb art m1, warum m1, weil ich glaub m1 ist der heizkreislauf 1, apple chip genau
das wird sein, das wird sein chat, das garantiert apple silicon in der heizung, ganz mit sicherheit,
jetzt weiß ich aber warum das so teuer ist, endlich hab ich jetzt mal die erklärung warum
meine heizung 4000 euro gekostet hat, wobei ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher ob die wirklich
so viel gekostet hat, zumindest auf amazon kostet die angeblich 4000 euro, was das für
ein overlay ist, hier du meinst die leiste, das ist i3 status rs, rust, i3 status rs,
rs da, kann alles mögliche von zeug, kann auch diesen komischen wie heißt das nochmal
powerline style, den ich ja persönlich gar nicht so mag, so set betrieb art, wie krieg
ich set betriebart für meine heizung schau doch nochmal in der conf nach den ganzen
modi der heizung welche konf du meinst hier in der xml 300 ja betrieb betriebsart ok betriebsart
haben wir zu bieten folgendes 0 ist warmwasser 01 ist red was auch immer 02 ist norm 04 ist
hwwfs was auch immer 03 ist heizung und warmwasser und 05 ist abschalt alles klar aber wie setze
ich das jetzt set betriebsart also ich würde sagen wir legen da jetzt einfach mal was an
wir copy pasten uns das wir copy pasten uns jetzt einfach mal set betriebsart rüber set
betrieb art m1 get get betrieb art war das hier get betrieb art macht aber ein paar
lehrzeichen bevor das man nämlich was erkennt so set betrieb art ich nenne das jetzt einfach
mal um so in hoffentlich geht dann adresse 23011 ba setze betriebsart perfekt jawoll
device id ich glaube nicht dass man das einfach so machen kann glaube nicht dass das funktioniert
die sache ist nur die warum ich mich das bisher nicht getraut hatte ich hatte mir angst dass
ich sachen verstelle bei der heizung gleich raucht die heizung ab ich mach das mal raus
was was passiert denn jetzt was passiert denn jetzt get get betrieb art ok wir machen ich
mach das da unten noch mal hinten unten dran so dann sieht das dann sieht es einheitlich
aus set betrieb art get betrieb art schauen wir mal da hatten wir das mal neu probieren
es mal aus wenn ihr den nachrichten kommt boomer bringt heizung zum exponieren weiß
ich bescheid schauen wir mal set betriebsart nope da muss ich mit warm wasser hinten dran
oh jetzt sogar gecrashed guck mal null weh ne funktioniert nicht gucken ob die heizung
noch schon feuer gefangen hat ne sieht noch alles gut aus die heizung ist nicht gecrashed
das auslese das auslese programm ist gecrashed so jetzt müssen wir googeln jetzt vorbei
set betriebsart wie control d hast ja auch die parameter aus der xml geworfen ja habe
ich aber ich glaube nicht dass es damit was zu tun hat das waren ja parameter für das
ganz ganz alte protokoll hallo wie du denn 300 set betrieb art zeigt mal ja hier hier
hier hatte was also von 2018 top aktuell massive weiß man sofort bescheid sinnvolle readouts
aus den für 20 cb hinterlegt was zum teufel ist 20 cb hier ah guck mal hier get device
type da kann ich auslesen was ich für eine heizung habe das ist schon mal gut das ist
das ist nice das ist nice machen wir jetzt details also hier bin die client
ne man muss noch mehr machen details die back also wie gesagt wenn die heizung raucht leute
an wissen wir bescheid wow monkeys alter ist 20 c 20 cb ja die back wieder anauen ok ok
bei dem ist es 20 c 2 bei mir ist es 20 c b 00 2 b 00 01114 alles klar obviously ist das
was anderes aber es ist ja ganz klar was das ist oder also ich glaube da müssen wir jetzt
müssen wir uns gar keine frage mehr stellen was das ist automatisch export meiner wiesmann
heizung interessant guck mal ich bin ich der einzige der sowas hat ihn am bei jetzt systemkennung
oh guck mal der hat der hat es hier richtig richtig nice gemacht oho guck mal der hat
die dinger sogar ordentlich benannt aktuelle betriebsart alter big brain time hier betriebsart
abschaltbetrieb nur warmwasser heizen und warmwasser dauerrettbetrieb was auch immer
ok nice hat er hat er auch sowas wie set set betrieb art rett gleich reduziert ah verstehe
betriebsart nice 2323 ich habe da irgendwie so meine bedenken ob ich random auf irgendwelche
adressen die ich da jetzt finde irgendwas schreiben soll moment moment da gibt es doch
irgendwelche pdf's vom hersteller pdf vitogate 200 alles klar die brauchen wir wine browser
warum alles in der welt ist in dieser internen default reinfolge der wine browser als erstes
drin firefox aufmachen ah jetzt jetzt wissen wir bescheid 20 cb ach tatsächlich guck mal
das 20 cb ist anscheinend der interne name von der steuerung das das kann schon sein
guck mal hier 20 cb 20 cb 20 cb also ich hab ne 200 irgendwas w oder f ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher ok und die steuerung ist eine vitotronik 200 h0 oder ho1b obvius alles klar weiß man
normalerweise was seine heizung hat sollte man wissen blamongo 9 monate huge subscriptions
m1 ausgang niveau heizkennlinie so also get betrieb art hat ja funktioniert so und wenn
get betrieb art funktioniert get betrieb ane moment dann gehe ich mal von aus dass die
adresse richtig ist get betrieb get betrieb art m1 nicht m1 get betrieb art so 2301 als
adresse 2301 findet er nicht findet er in 232 was der andere hatte ah anscheinend 2323
doch richtig ich glaube die default settings sind einfach müll was hat der was hatte der
typ hier nochmal 2323 ja ok 2323 ist wohl die richtige adresse wobei ist das überhaupt
die adresse es ist die es ist die technical id ok jetzt probieren wir mal aus also get
betrieb art 2323 ne moment ok wait 2323 starten wir das nochmal und gucken was der jetzt
ausliest warum wird ja eine heizung programmiert die heizung wird nicht programmiert es wird
die heizung ausgelesen und dann modus gesetzt so get betrieb art oh kate red red was auch
immer moment leute ich zeige euch jetzt mal die richtigen heckermann die richtige heckermann
geschichte also mir ist das grad ein bisschen zu nervig dass sie immer mit wimm hin und
her zu zudings pass mal auf pass mal auf massive massive heckermann stellts machen wir jetzt
so sshfs sshfs sshfs das ganze vcontrol verzeichnis nach sshfs mounten bam sshfs zack code öffnen
jawoll trust so ich hab mir jetzt gerade das filesystem vom raspberry pi gemountet in
den ordner bei mir lokal deswegen kann ich jetzt sowas wie visual studio code lokal aufmachen
und mir die dateien angucken so xml 300 vcontrol und vitur das ist richtig exquisite muss man
sich merken ist total easy geht nur mit rechnern die ssh enabled haben natürlich und wahrscheinlich
auch nicht mit windows desktop hinter ich habe keine ahnung was habe ich für ein das da
ich habe das bing image of the day das ist anscheinend das bing image of the day übrigens
der einzige grund für was ich bing verwende x forwarding ja ganz bestimmt ok jetzt betrieb
also 2053 bei 2053 ist doch falsch ich hab doch 20 cb als wo hast du das gesettet mit
dem background irgendwo in meinem startup was haben sich die wiesmannleute denn da wieder
ausgedacht wer soll denn da durchblicken also setbetrieb art funktioniert nicht also ich
brauche schon mal 20 cb das ist ja schon mal es ist ja schon mal falsch ich hab ja gar
nicht 2053 ich habe 20 cb so das heißt ich starte das jetzt noch mal mit 20 cb vielleicht
geht es dann geht gar nicht mehr direkt direkt kaputt warum vielleicht weil das ding meine
heizung gar nicht als 20 cb erkennt die weiß type gab es doch nee hier die weiß id ist
20 cb aber es gab doch irgendwas mit def type oder so hier die weiß type ach guckt mal hier
match der was was ist und ich wurde als unknown gematcht das heißt ich muss jetzt hier zusätzlich
wahrscheinlich noch was eintragen so wie dieser typ das hier auch gemacht hat der hat hier
auch eingetragen er hat eine system kennung blablabla 22 cb dumm sweep dankeschön für
den zapp also dann kopieren wir das hier mal und sagen nicht 20 cb sondern 20 20 cb 002
0000 114 beim ausprobieren ob es jetzt funktioniert get betrieb alter warum nicht get def get def
type jetzt hat das aber richtig erkannt ich habe vergessen das einzutragen wirklich wo
dann das ist was anderes also jetzt sollte er das aber eigentlich eigentlich erkennen
was ist denn wenn ich das ganz raus werfe aha ane get ah alter was mit der musik los
alles klar hinter nur alles klar ok get betrieb
art funktioniert wieder wir haben es richtig gemacht ok set betrieb art 2 3 2 3 machen
wir jetzt auch hier aber dann fehlt dann fehlt doch der dann stimmt das doch hier wieder
nicht guck mal betriebs art benamung macht mich fertig b a unit b a betriebs art so abkürzung
b a warum auch immer man hier die abkürzung nimmt und da ausgeschrieben was auch immer
das stimmt jetzt bei mir ja nicht ich habe hier diesen ganzen krempel hier nicht was
ist denn fs hww fs was was ist das überhaupt
net betrieb betriebs art hat er unit b a betriebs art b a abschaltbetrieb nur warmwasser
heizen und warmwasser also ich müsste eigentlich aktuell eins bekommen was ist denn hier als
eins eingetragen das stimmt das stimmt das ist richtig ich habe mich aktuell nur warmwasser
dann stimmt das was dieser typ hier hat dann stimmt das also ok dann oder was hat der andere
hier drinnen in dieser oh jetzt wirds ja auf einmal so laut entscheidet euch mal entscheidet
euch mal also guck mal hier was hat er dann hier betriebs art aus ww hw genau das ist
das was ich auch brauche mehr brauche ich nicht 0 1 aus ok 0 1 warm 0 0 aus 0 1 warmwasser
0 2 heizen plus warmwasser was sagen denn die offiziellen sachen hier ok 0 abschalt
1 warmwasser 2 heizen plus dauert dann ist das sogar richtig was der typ hier hat dann
nehmen wir das nur dass ich das anders nenne ok jetzt jetzt schauen wir mal was hat was
hat er hier nicht dass ich irgendwie ansatzweise durchblicken durchblicken würde was ich da
mache also abschalt moment das stimmt ja überhaupt nicht was ich jetzt hier kopiert
habe seck das falsche was ich kopiert habe das da ich habe das falsche kopiert das falsche
kopiert so also abschaltbetrieb nur warmwasser heizen und warmwasser dauernd rettbetrieb
dauernd normalbetrieb ok gucken wir mal ob das jetzt funktioniert da sollte jetzt als
antwort kommen nur warmwasser ist das mit telefon und codec schon fertig nein schauen
wir mal get betrieb hat nur warmwasser nice nice funktioniert so also dann benenne ich
das mal um also text abschaltbetrieb ist doof das heißt einfach off nur warmwasser heißt
ww heizen plus warmwasser heißt ha plus ww so wie es in dem anderen auch drinne stand
das brauche ich nicht wer benutzt denn sowas hier schon komm on brah wer benutzt schon
solche dinger blutet blutet alles blutet brauchen wir nicht warmwasser betrieb also ok leute
es wird zeit für die abstimmung ob es funktioniert oder nicht du machst dafür ein pr soll ich
dafür pr machen das ist ganz spezifisch für meine heizung das muss jeder selbst eintragen
also prediction falsches falsches falsches layout ah funktioniert ach so abstimmung
ja wir hätten prediction machen können aber dann machen wir nur abstimmung wir machen
wir machen nochmal abstimmung es reicht wir müssen ja nicht immer unsere ganze channel
points setzen funktioniert ja nein tja schauen wir mal also die sache ist die ich werde das
jetzt setzen ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob man das erkennt wenn das gesetzt ist muss
auf jeden fall die infrarot led ausmachen dass man was erkennt 19 und 37 also man sollte
auf dem display dann irgendwas erkennen von von brenner oder feuer in irgendeiner art
und weise wenn ich umschalte als das falls es überhaupt funktioniert ich setz erstmal
den betrieb auf das was es gerade ist set betrieb ww ok ok es gibt keinen fehler es
gibt keinen fehler das heißt prinzipiell sollte das funktionieren also die meisten sagen ich
bin immer überrascht wie viel vertrauen da der chat drin hat dass es funktioniert die
fragen gehen immer mit ja aus aber oftmals klappt es auch nicht ich habe kameras ja an
meine heizung sogar war hier dank für den zapp believers versus daub das genau six hat
im also ich glaube wir können festhalten dass so drei viertel der meinung sind es funktioniert
und ein viertel denkt es funktioniert nicht schauen wir mal also heizen plus warm wasser
ich habe keine ahnung ob es funktioniert ich habe keine ahnung ob es funktioniert
das display zeigt nichts an vielleicht steigt die wassertemperatur klein ja gett betriebsart
kann ich machen das hat bestimmt funktioniert aber ob das wirklich jetzt heizung plus aber
wir sehen es auf dem display nicht ich hätte gedacht auf dem display sieht man es vielleicht
ok ich ich schalte das wieder um auf nur warm wasser weil ich habe kein bock dass die heizung
jetzt angeht doch ich weiß wir lesen die kesseltemperatur aus das geht doch warte mal das das geht
doch irgendwie ermittelt die kesseltemperatur gett tempkist die benahmung von den macht
mich echt fertig gett tempkist 34 grad brenner es gibt doch den brennerzustand ja gett brenner
gett brenner status null ich weiß nicht ob man das direkt sieht was soll das heißen
tempkist tempkist heißt ermittelt die kesseltemperatur kessel ist temperatur gett temperatur kessel
ist soll das heißen wer auch immer sich das ausgedacht hat der muss wirklich schon next
next level hirn haben dass man auf sowas kommt ok set betriebsart heizen und warm wasser
funktioniert leute es funktioniert der brenner brennt ok jetzt stelle ich mal wieder zurück
auf warm wasser ja gut der fährt jetzt der fährt jetzt runter gerade jetzt wieder aus
nice ich also ich würde echt sagen dass das funktioniert ja man sieht auf der cam leider
nicht weil der bildschirm schoner an ist man müsste diesen bildschirm schoner einfach
ausmachen wozu gibt es überhaupt einen bildschirm schoner bei einer heizung was ist das für
ein schwachsinn wer hat es ausgedacht wozu braucht man bei einer heizung einen bildschirm
schoner geh runter ne geh jetzt nicht in den keller
wisst ihr was ich machen könnte ich könnte einen switchspot unten hinstellen ich hab
doch so ich hab doch so einen switchspot der kann für mich tasten drücken guckt so einen
müsste ich unten an die heizung machen der kann für dich drücken beste sowas müsste
ich dann unten in den keller machen der kann einfach für mich den knopf drücken doch
das funktioniert leute das funktioniert das funktioniert leider funktioniert das mit
der infrarot led an nicht so gut was mache ich infrarot cut na gut jetzt habe ich infrarot
led an aber infrarot gekattet funktioniert tatsächlich halbwegs ja man sieht man sieht
man sieht nicht so viel leider sieht man auf dem display nichts aber ich würde ich würde
fast sagen dass das funktioniert ja jetzt brenner status ist 0 so und betriebsart kessel
temp 33 betriebsart ist wieder runter auf warmwasser ja also das das ergibt sinn ich
würde ich würde mal vermuten das funktioniert ich gucke mir das morgen mal morgen früh
dann mal vor ort an wenn ich in keller aber ich laufe jetzt nicht in keller runter tipp
auf das display dass das stream was sie da habe ich keinen bock drauf jetzt in keller
zu gehen ok also das scheint ja wirklich zu funktionieren die kamera ist nicht nur schwarz
weiß aber infrarot ist halt nur infrarot bilder sind halt nur schwarz weiß ok also
ich würde sagen dass das an sich funktioniert ne mache ich nicht keine chancen weird champ
würdet ihr denn für mich in keller gehen
ich glaube euch kein wort leute ich glaube euch kein wort typischer chat debate wieder
richtiger debate gut also das das funktioniert anscheinend das kommunizieren mit der heizung
da bin ich doch schon mal da bin ich doch mal schon mal sehr zufrieden so jetzt müssen
wir noch ein paar sachen machen und zwar ich muss gucken ob das board funktioniert was
da oben drauf ist der automation fett ob der analog digital konverter funken funktioniert
muss ich mir noch angucken github automation hat da haben die bestimmt example codes also
was heißt bestimmt ich weiß dass die example codes haben dafür und dann lesen wir jetzt
einfach mal den adc aus und schauen ob das funktioniert analog automation hat analog
one reads automation hat examples analog tai jawoll er funktioniert 17 17 volt auf der
leitung gerade und wenn es jetzt klingelt hätte es 20 aber es klingelt nicht gut das
funktioniert auch so das heißt dieses automation ding funktioniert das auslesen von der heizung
funktioniert auch dann muss ich mir eigentlich bloß noch ein dotnet 5 drauf installieren
weil ich das brauche für meine software die ich da drauf haue warum baust du deine heizungsüberwachung
beziehungsweise wo willst du diese verwenden ich hatte ja die ganze zeit schon eine heizungsüberwachung
ich hatte das dashboard hier du siehst da nichts weil das kabel kaputt war ich kann
es dir aber zeigen hier sechs monate zurück so sieht das dann normalerweise aus zoomen
wir mal ran hier zum beispiel siehst du dann nachts kessel temperatur geht runter warum
dort net weil ich sie scharp fanboy bin ich weiß ihr habt es noch nie gesehen deswegen
zeige ich euch jetzt ja auch so hier wieder nachts also das habe ich die ganze zeit schon
laufen aber jetzt habe ich wenigstens wieder ein kabel was funktioniert wobei mir das
noch nicht gereicht dass ich einfach nur die werte auslesen kann ich habe jetzt ich habe
jetzt versucht ob man auch werte setzen kann und ja das funktioniert das haben wir gerade
ausprobiert da gibt es so was tolles das nennt sich set betrieb art also wer sich das ausgedacht
hat ist wirklich nicht mal ganz ganz bei sin da kann ich jetzt umschalten zwischen warm
wasser und warm wasser und heizung so und ich gehe dann in mein home assistant das ist
sind dashboard demo ich zeige euch noch mal das demo dashboard weil ich mein aktuelles
home assistant dashboard nicht liegen will das ist die offizielle home assistant demo
da werde ich mir dann hier so einen knopf machen und da steht dann dran heizung sommer
winter modus oder sowas oder heizung an aus einfach nur so und dann kann ich umschalten
und unter der haube wird er dann umschalten set betriebsart h plus ww das ist übrigens
eh nur alles fake hier drin ja das muss ich dann programmieren noch also das heißt ich
werde einmal wieder den prometheus exporter da reaktivieren dass ich wieder mein dashboard
habe und ich werde irgendeine integration programmieren für home assistant über diese
home assistant mqtt discovery funktion dass er dann erkennt was es für kommandos gibt
und dass er zum beispiel den switch hat get set betriebsart warum steht in der xml sparschwein
macht das hier sparbetrieb sparschwein weiß ich nicht weil der typ der diese xml erstellt
hat gedacht hat diese funktion heißt sparschwein was weiß ich wir haben sogar get betrieb
sparschwein jetzt ergibt alles sinn nice ok ich werde mir jetzt schnell noch dotnet
5 drauf hauen das brauche ich für meine software auf der auf der raspberry pi muss
ich mal kurz gucken pi dotnet github da gab es irgendeinen installer script für was alles
richtig verlinkt und macht und tut das da und wir machen jetzt das was man natürlich
machen sollte also immer immer man sollte immer unbekannte sachen von github nach sudo
bashpipen das ist ganz ganz essentiell immer alles nach sudo bashpipen ohne rein zu gucken
vorher geht das ganze vielleicht auch ohne hut geht das geht das auch ohne hut einfach
nur noch bash
natürlich jetzt mal ernsthaft ihr solltet nie was nach bashpipen und schon gar nicht
nach sudo bash wenn ihr es euch nicht vorher angeguckt habt und am besten ist immer vorher
runterladen da noch mal reingucken und dann ausführen aber das kenne ich das ist ein
installer für dotnet auf raspberry pi so dass es funktioniert weil der offizielle microsoft
installer eben nicht richtig funktioniert auf dem raspberry pi warum auch immer
auch sagt leute ich muss ich muss mir noch usb verlängerungen bestellen bei amazon fällt
mir gerade ein usb verlängerung gibt es da wieder irgendwas schönes im angebot nie
maso usb extension 9,99 2 stück wie lang 2 meter dienstag mittwoch ich will es am dienstag
eigentlich will ich es am montag haben was ist ja mit euch los hier anzeige ist raus
es ist samstag ja aber ab heute nacht fährt amazon wieder tuesday tuesday muss man da eingeloggt
sein monday geht doch aber das ist nur einer von suduo nicht sudo suduo suduo
der handy kommt am montag glhf monday gibt es da noch mehr ne nur die nur die china chinesen
kommen am montag wieder hier monday monday was ist denn das was brauche ich dafür verlängern
das ist 20 zentimeter brauche ich doch keine verlängerung für 30 zentimeter ist doch
nix warum soll ich 30 zentimeter verlängern wenn ich auch für weniger 2 meter verlängern
kann ok was ist nicht 5 meter was gibt es das 5 meter usb extension 5 meter 6,27 67 perfekt
und das ganze jetzt bitteschön noch für montag jawoll ich will eine passive verlängerung
nix mit led und so komischem krempel da gibt es nicht monday hier bam 5 meter jawoll ne
debatet warum ist das aufgetaucht mit 5 meter nur 1 meter ai ai ai hast du die videos von
easy gesehen wie sie ihre highspeed anschlüsse werden sogar für spieler und gamer ne zeig
mal her das muss ich mir angucken easy nicht easy easy schenkt mal link zu irgendeinem youtube
video bisschen bisschen provider cringe muss jetzt noch sein ok ich glaube bis montag kriege
ich da nix was richtig sagt kann man das sortieren lassen nach liefer lieferzeitpunkt
das hatte ich eben provider genau ja es gibt nur die es gibt nur diese die aktiven verlängerungen
bis 5 meter man braucht doch für usb 2 5 meter kein aktiv verlängerung oder doch komplett
overrated she baited outdated ok fastest delivery heißt wahrscheinlich express das will ich
nicht machen aber zahle ich ja nochmal 8 euro extra dafür ne muss eingeloggt sein ich kann
mich jetzt hier aber nicht einloggen youtube easy werbung ob crow easy money
easy money alles klar also wenn ich hier nach easy such kommt nix soll ich halt easy dsl suchen
ja also ok welches ist besonders cringe ich erzähl was soll ich aufmachen angebot ohne
haken dauerhaft günstiges internet entdecke faire so funktioniert gut angebot ohne haken ok
zeig mal ja ich dachte das wäre mario kart musik das gehört dazu
so sollte der preis dann auch nicht bleiben
vor die rakete
ja und es ist auch noch wundervoen
war noch ganz normale dsl provider werbung
hä warum hat dieses video so viele aufrufe
was sagen die muss man nicht verstehen
ja beim schnee stellt frage ich mich das auch rust shocking developer interview das ist das
riecht doch schon allein bei dem titel nach es ist das du ok ok also die negativen daumen
runter hat es wahrscheinlich nicht weil das schlecht ist sondern weil die rust fanboys
alles disliken was was ging rast geht aber quantos días en total más o menos
ist der chat im weg oh ja der chat ist im weg upst
sie werden inkämmlich
in étant
der
es
c++ مث
c++
Ja, und so ist es ja auch.
Nein, die machen das nicht.
Ja, T++ ist halt einfach fail.
Doch ist es, also C ist aber C++ nicht.
Ja die neuen Standard sacken ja genauso.
Das stimmt doch gar nicht.
Ja das stimmt.
Jetzt...
Naja, da habe ich schon bessere gesehen
Das stimmt tatsächlich es gibt ganz viele sagen so nach dem motto alles neu schreiben in rust was natürlich schwachsinnig ist aber
Es gibt projekte auf github die haben nur viele sterne nicht weil sie sinnvoll sind oder weil sie in rust programmiert sind
Gau übrigens auch
Das wird mich tatsächlich gar nicht wundern
Kann rust performance mit c++ beteiligen ja
Naja, also da habe ich schon bessere gesehen das jetzt nicht so lustig
Also da habe ich echt schon bessere gesehen
Ja gut das stimmt die rust syntax ist zu big brain für mich
Das stimmt wohl
Naja, da habe ich schon bessere gesehen
Da habe ich schon bessere gesehen
Legendaire ist ja der
Nvidia engineer reacts zur weniger ram in der 970
Battlefield 2042 in trouble, komm wir lassen uns mal chibane, wir lassen wir lassen uns mal wobei das nicht so gut ist
Das gucken wir morgen, das gucken wir nicht jetzt. Guck mal morgen. So
Welche internetgeschwindigkeit brauchst du wirklich okay? Lass uns mal von easy erklären
Das sind unsere musternutzer
Okay, sebi der server, stefanie der serienjunkie, die fabers
Und zacky der zocker na dann
Gibt es einen grund warum die rust syntax so komplex sein muss ja na ja teilweise
Weil rust viel zur compile zeit checkt aber ich finde sie teilweise auch unnötig
Kompliziert
Warum zockt er überhaupt auf dem notebook was ist das schon wieder für ein zocker
Notebook, was ist denn das schon wieder für ein schwachsinn?
Und warum brauchen den surfer ein tarif von vodafone
Aha
Und das ganze Ende das ganze Video ist schon hier drüben da zu diameter bravery
Skype von wann ist das video 2020
Okay, die sind wirklich hinten dran
benötigter speed mindestens fünf ok und woran haben die das jetzt festgemacht
Ja zumindest knapp, knapp, knapp kannst du gucken, aber nee eigentlich kannst du keine
YouTube Videos gucken.
Nein 5 MBit, 5 MBit reichen, wenn überhaupt nur sehr knapp, aber eigentlich reichen sie
gar nicht für 1080p, 1080p sind doch irgendwie, irgendwie um die 8 MBit oder so.
Die braucht 10 ok, warum braucht die 10, warum braucht die 10, ich meine die macht genau
das gleiche wie das Surfer, nur dass die, nur dass die Serien schaut auf Netflix.
YouTube 1080p geht nicht mit 5 MBit, YouTube macht es halt dynamisch, das ist dann, wenn
du nur 5 MBit gehst, dann halt runter auf 84 oder 720 oder so, die 16K Serien guckt
die sich an, aha, ah die Farbos sind jetzt am Start, ja, 25 LOL, 25 ja mindestens, mindestens,
25 für ne Familie, das ist doch, das ist doch der Witz.
25 für ne Familie, das reicht doch hinten und vorne nicht, 50 eventuell, aber ehrlich
gesagt eigentlich müssten das 100 plus sein, in UHD, ja, die Konsole braucht nichts, ich
weiß gar nicht was es immer soll, die Leute tun so als brauchen gerade Leute die spielen
besonders viel, das stimmt nicht, Bandbreiten technisch ist Gaming Traffic nix, hallo, ach
ja, ah der braucht 5 MBit mehr als die Familie, alles klar, ich würde, das ist ein bescheuerter
Vergleich, die Familie braucht auf jeden Fall mehr und er, er kommt damit wahrscheinlich
sogar theoretisch hin, aber ganz ehrlich damit würde ich heutzutage nicht mehr rumkrebsen,
noch Fragen, ja was ist das für ein bescheuerter Vergleich, Schwachsinn, also das einzige was
halbwegs passt mag vielleicht, was, was, Youtube braucht 0,5 MBit, was, was, mit 0,5 MBit kann
ich nicht mal dieses Video hier angucken und das reicht für 1080p auf gar keinen Fall,
nein, gerade online Spielen brauchen nichts an Bandbreite, das Downloaden der Spiele ja,
das vielleicht schon, live online Spiele mit an, das was mit Abstand am wenigsten Bandbreite
verbraucht, steht am höchsten, warum, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, vielleicht
spielen die alle Stadia über die Cloud, ist doch bescheuert, das ist doch richtig bescheuert,
es kann jeder VP9 komprimieren wenn er will, die meisten wollen das nicht, die meisten
machen ganz normal H264 weil es kompatibler ist, dass die Leute keine Ahnung haben wovon
sie sprechen, ja das ist echt guter Witz, wird sie nicht,
richtig blödsinnig, guck die Katze ok, das hat meine erste auch gemacht, die hat im Schlaf
immer gezappelt, 16 Monat, Dankeschön für den Zapir, nice
so, morgen früh bin ich wieder am Start Leute, reicht, reicht für heute, wir haben das gemacht
was wir machen wollten, oder ich hab das gemacht was ich machen wollte, wir, stimmt ja gar
nicht, ich hab gemacht, ihr habt geguckt und da gehe ich jetzt nämlich off und bin morgen
früh wieder mit aufwacht streamen am Start, ich hab 911, 21 Monate, huge hyper subscriptions
hier, danke für die ganzen Subs Leute heute, ich hab noch ein bisschen was übersehen hier,
glaube ich der Mario ist noch am Start, Doom Swap, Nekorock hab ich auch übersehen, ne
Flamongo hatte ich schon, danke Leute für die ganzen subscriptions hier, also wir sehen
uns, bis denn, C U